no one is ever perfect and just to
remember that
progress is better than perfection i'm
so excited that you're going to be doing
this
zero waste challenge with me are you
down to show me your trash
from a regular day i've got some seaweed
snacks sparkling water root beer i made
this
yesterday this is all of my
waist so since you hardly make any trash
and you're already really low waist
maybe this can more
be a tutorial and just showing people
how you avoid waste we could do that i'm
excited
for you to show us how we can reduce
waste and be more low waste
hi everybody it's leah thomas and i'm
going to be showing you
all how i reduce waste and telling you
all about the ways that i
do get so here is my kind of like
mason jar collection it's absolutely
made my life a lot easier
and it's just so easy to always have
like containers to put stuff in
it's really what helps me not really
have a ton of waste so what are some
other things in my house that i can show
you
i like to package a lot of my food
in these sorts of bags this is a way
that i also say
low waste at my house they come in all
different shapes and sizes
if i don't want to use plastic when i'm
out and about
i have things like this they have wooden
forks
and knives and pulp cutlery
i try to be like super forgiving of
myself like for example i really wanted
some bagels
right so i have this bagel
and it comes in plastic and
i don't know i need to eat so and i
really want bagels and these happen to
be the ones that were sold at trader
joe's
so we actually met when we did a video
where you were explaining the
intersection between
environmentalism and black lives matter
and since then
i know you have started this awesome
thing called intersectional
environmentalists could you tell me a
little bit more about that
intersectional environmentalists is an
online platform that started
during the summer of 2020 that's all
about exploring the relationship between
social justice and environmentalism
because there are so many links and
interconnections there
really trying to make environmental
education accessible
to everyone this is like a daily vitamin
that i use
and it comes in packaging that is
compostable
and biodegradable and i just pour these
refills into
my glass container so that way i don't
have to
go to the store and you know
buy a bunch of plastic and things like
that even things like
you know cotton swabs just making sure
that i'm getting some sort of like
easily recyclable packaging
because the majority of consumer waste
actually comes from packaging and that's
pretty messed up
i'm primarily plant-based and i just
really
need certain vitamins but i like to
prioritize like glass containers because
those are really easily recyclable
in the past i've defined zero waste as
trying to send as little as possible
to landfill i'm wondering how you would
define zero waste
so i've been gravitating towards the
terminology low waste versus zero waste
in reality it's just saying okay if you
have plastic making sure
you're able to recycle it doing as much
as you can
to divert any waste away from a landfill
to my surprise i almost felt like i kind
of
passed a test when i was talking to art
because
apparently i'm one of the more low-waste
people
that she's talked to even as an
environmental blogger
i get sent lots of things so the
majority of my waste is honestly from
packaging or from food just so you get a
little
sneak peek here are some of my packages
that i
get thankfully a lot of it does come in
recycled
packaging i also donate a lot of those
things to people who need it
i also gift my mom with a lot of things
or like my employees and my co-workers
and stuff like that
how do you think the zero waste movement
can grow zero waste like we were talking
about before
it's been almost positioned as something
that only wealthy
folks can do and you can't buy your way
into sustainability
i don't really see a lot of
representation of people of color
or people like my grandma there are a
lot of people who are living low waste
out of
necessity it's actually kind of funny
how consumerism has infiltrated the zero
waste
circle and that's really not what it's
about so i think that's kind of been a
shift that i'm seeing when i'm
you know kind of transitioning more so
towards you know low waist
the truth is zero waste is low waist you
can never
be zero waste it's just like striving to
do that
and it's funny too because the most zero
waste thing is to not
buy anything but then now there's this
whole like
industry of products that have been
built around
supporting the zero waste lifestyle
which is i think sort of inherently not
zero waste
i like to use laundry detergent
that doesn't really require a ton of
waste whether it's things that aren't
using plastic
so something like this it's from drops
and it comes in like a cardboard box
which is really easy to
recycle it's unscented so it's not using
any like toxic waste and dyes
i feel like this is kind of fun as an
environmentalist
sometimes honestly like i always feel
like i'm not
doing enough and sometimes i feel
ashamed about the trash that i do have
but i guess it's really nice and
important to remind yourself of the
things that you are doing
so that's a little bit about how i try
to
reduce my waste around the house
i recycle when i can and i try to make
sure the packaging that i'm buying
always has some sort of strategy for its
end of life
and also not shaming myself if i'm not
perfect because we're in a panorama
right now so it's totally okay
you're already really far along on your
low-waist journey
and being an environmentalist what would
you
say to people who are starting on their
journey you know you can't buy your way
into sustainability
i don't want to confuse anyone to think
that you have to like be this mega
consumer in order to be zero waste
because
honestly a lot of people probably have
all the tools and solutions already at
home
for people who have never heard the term
intersectional environmentalism can you
explain
what that is intersectional
environmentalism
in essence just means taking an approach
to environmentalism
that also evaluates you know class race
gender sexuality etc and also
accessibility and how do we find out
more
about intersectional environmentalists
you can check out our website at
intersectionalenvironmentalist.com
also our instagram intersectional
environments list
[Music]
you